they just show up right at nine yeah oh
yeah they do they like to they like to
live on the edge
I mean it's not live why wouldn't you
just wait 10 minutes or you just you
just go at nine oh because the the
ability to razz each other is right
right the comedy gold hey
come on all right buddy good good
8 54. I know do you think do you think
he's in his car stressing a little bit
like he's he's starting to look at the
clock a little more than you would
normally look at the clock yeah I don't
know I mean yesterday I was I mean I'm
usually rolling in at five till that's
usually around the time I just happen to
I drop my kids off and I got here yeah
that's what I did yeah you did yeah how
many kids you have two eight and seven
eight and seven yeah
okay you're in it you got you're eight
and eleven boys wait what did I just say
hey you said eight and seven I
I'm tired I have eight and eleven too
yeah
I said eight and seven
both out real quick and then and reverse
order too
eight seven five and two yeah
two girls two girls yeah
only boys all boys we're an all-boy show
it's kind of surprising actually it was
a weird phase of of people having boys
so I had a boy you had two boys Robin
two boys wow Hornsby had two boys wow
martyr had a boy Roselle had a boy
murder had two boys Mark had two boys
Roselle had a boy Roselle had a boy
literally every like in in like in
succession like Everett was like oh
we're having a boy and it was like we're
having a boy oh my God we're having a
boy we're having another boy there might
have been something in the water and
then uh my some somebody told me some
stupid theory that they're like oh yeah
they're they're putting stuff in the
water to build an army to fight the
Chinese and I was like I was like then
they're gonna have the worst like La
Army of like like I'm not doing that I
am not doing that I'm not fighting those
people is this Tech Electric are we
really using this much gas
are we really using this much gas I'm
sorry but like these rations like can I
can I get like
[Laughter]
I am also here did it literally start
Megan you're here it's been starting
really yeah oh God what did I say yeah
we'll cut all the events we'll cut all
the offensive stuff that you said
um
well you know uh
you're here and thank you for joining us
uh you are you are as talented as you
are professional because
I would say you're in time you're not on
time
so you made it at nine o'clock I'm like
yeah right a second oh you're drawing is
still here to talk about me we're here
to talk about Michael not well we we're
here to talk about Michael not until you
sort of very rudely
walked in halfway through his first
minute of time
which made it about you I'm sorry
Michael yeah
pre-interview this is really you guys
just show up literally oh it's just okay
yeah this is there's nothing this is
National about this which is sort of
entertainment on the internet you know
this is It's just sort of age we're
living in yeah it just sort of begins
and yeah it just sort of yeah I didn't
know when it really started I didn't
know you're not happening
the audience doesn't know when it begins
or ends either so it doesn't doesn't
really matter yeah it's fine Michael
Naughton uh one of our favorite uh guest
stars
one of our most loved guest stars I
would say loved by love because I looked
up a ranking and I was uh oh 16th but I
think it went from
most sane I don't know if it was like
insane at first I think the waiters yeah
you're a straight man that's why we yeah
that's why we like your character so
much yeah but I don't think I realized
how few sane straight people because as
I was going on like usually a show you
guys are crazy and there's someone there
to balance but uh there's no one here to
balance it used yet no and by the way
for for the audience out there who's not
familiar with the term straight man
we're not talking about uh sexual
orientation we're talking about do
people not know what a straight a
straight man is I don't know I think
most people I think most people know
what a straight man is I just want to be
clear because we're saying like Evan
Costello so way back then there was
because when he says like no one on the
show is straight and blah blah blah oh
yeah talking about he's talking about
before there isn't a dedicated straight
man on itself it is that your reactions
are more in line with the audience than
the characters reactions to things so
that the audience looks at the
characters through similar eyes as you
do within the context of the show so uh
they get to enjoy your incredulous uh
yeah your reactions like what is
happening or what are you doing right
right or even a simple okay uh can be
really funny when you know when
delivered correctly but but playing a
funny straight man is is quite difficult
I think that's one of the reasons why we
got our hooks into you and like latched
onto you and was like okay we got to
keep this guy around no thanks thanks a
few people that can be truly truly funny
and be and be totally straight oh thanks
yeah I remember the first time I saw
Michael non do you do you guys remember
have you seem at the ground I saw him at
the Groundlings yeah were we together
well I remember we we went
sort of Scouting For like people that we
that were super duper funny but that we
had maybe never seen or or hadn't I
don't know and we went to the
Groundlings uh I mean and I remember
seeing yeah I remember seeing you you I
remember seeing what was I doing yeah
20 years ago don't be offended these
guys don't remember anything even about
their own show who was in that that
groundling uh was that that was the that
was the main company
was in there no she was gone by then I
think when we saw well no no she because
she was in there she was in that show
yeah oh that specific show I don't know
because I was in it for a long time and
people came and yeah of course yeah but
Melissa was was in that show as well so
that show that you're talking about we
went it was uh it was a it was like an
anniversary because Caitlyn brought us
brought us there and it was uh it was
like celebrating whatever 20 years of
the Groundlings or something like that
and so no but at that point Melissa
McCarthy was was in the main company
okay as was wig okay yes still yes
that's right I remember Kristin being a
part of the company still yep and then
there was a couple sketches like Fame
famous SNL sketch is that Melissa done
at Groundlings and then you just see it
on SNL like almost line for line like
the ranch I remember watching that one
or yeah you know you're watching you're
like oh Jason today because it's doing
my part now
wow but yeah she was so good that's why
she was so amazed on the show because
she had been doing sketch comedy and she
was able to come in there with these but
there was a night at the Groundlings
where she had a sketch where she had a
crush on this guy so she brought him
some balloons and then she feels dumb so
she's trying to break the balloons and
at the Groundlings live she was trying
to break him and against the floor and
it broke and she broke her nose oh my
God on the ground and I was in the scene
so I'm the only one who didn't see it
because I'm sort of you know in the
scene in the whole audience is just like
watching her and I think blood came oh
my God and I had no idea everybody kind
of got it did she keep going yeah she
kept going yeah she kept going she kept
going and man yeah she did by the way
that's if you guys know that going that
think about how funny that is people are
watching that and they're like how did
they do that is the most amazing special
effect I've ever seen on stage so that
was a talented group that you were part
of and we poached you for It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia we watched on our
last podcast the um sweet D has a heart
attack episode which is your first
that's the last one yeah um where you
interview
um Mac and Charlie for the job that
they're being hired together yeah but
yeah we were wondering if that character
is in any way related to the rest like
did he lose his job and become a waiter
yeah what is it in your mind well in my
mind I was watching it two and the first
interaction at HR
she kind of likes you like you have such
a great relationship yeah yeah yeah he's
like I get to hire and then the waiter
from the beginning there's just an
energy that that he hates them so I'm
like can it be the same guy I wouldn't
even remember them
yes well so this is what we discussed
yesterday yeah possibly their twin
brothers we might establish that they're
twin brothers
twin people but not related
yeah yeah
they recognize the guy from the office
that interviewed them but of course they
never recognize the waiter he'll be like
now right it'd be fun to do the thing
where we see we keep seeing the guy from
The Office like behind a desk and we're
like we're sure that's the waiter and
then we see like waiter we're following
the waiter around we're trying we never
see them both in the same place and then
at the end the guy
don't give away the ending
no some somebody on Reddit was like that
guy got fired because he hired two
people at the same race okay like they
had thought about it more than oh then
me or maybe by the way to be fair we did
talk about this we we I remember the
discussion being we want Michael
Naughton for this because we don't think
anybody else can do it the way we're
picturing it and we've already used for
the waiter yes for the waiter is what
you're talking about you know it was a
pivotal pivotal character and we we
wanted to hire you we knew we knew we
needed somebody who's really really
funny but that could play a straight
play it totally straight you know what I
mean and and and the only person we just
couldn't get you out of our head so we
were like well there's no reason why
that guy couldn't have lost that job for
whatever reason and oh
yeah this is I remember I was talking
about this I mean that was how we
Justified it we're right it could be the
same guy or maybe it isn't I think
that's it was more of that it was like
if we needed to justify it it could be
the same guy but we don't you know I was
so afraid that when I showed up you guys
were gonna be like oh God this guy
played the yeah
you're so busy writing I can only do the
casting that has happened yes cast
someone years later that we had cast
earlier in the show and didn't realize
until they got to set really it was the
same person and then been like well it's
fine because it's been so long with dude
we specifically wanted you well that's
what I was afraid of so I when I showed
up I'm like do you guys know I played
the HR guy and you're like yeah
I did you gave us a shot but you waited
till the last second no no like as soon
as you came in here and makeup board I'm
like yeah thanks I was the HR and you
guys were like yeah we know we yeah
we liked you yeah but it's funny to
watch that because in the blue it's such
a we were talking about this uh on the
last one but um there it's such a that
scene this goes on and on and on in the
bloopers there's such a long section of
it that you forget how in the cut down
episode we barely were able to put all
so much of that funny stuff in because
it slowed the story down it just didn't
progress the story in any way so we
thought it was so funny it was great on
the bloopers but in the actual episode
The scene's so short do we have the
bloopers queued up
so for you for several years I've been
in complete charge of pretty much
everything in my life that's actually
that is okay
general statement more than that that's
actually that's actually me I'm I've
sort of I sort of have a grasp on what
I'm doing on a day-to-day basis
okay work history again it's just 2006
to 2007. Liaisons in business we both
treat our work as if it was the most
important things in our lives
okay uh 2005 to 2006 education odd jobs
here and there
now we yeah we're hearing this for them
yes because it wasn't in the script to
read off the resume that's that's
something we started improvising and
right started just messing around
because online people are like oh my God
this guy was cracking them up so much
that they brought him back but oh I was
just reading things off the resume but I
thought you guys wrote that no no so I
thought you were laughing at the the
stuff you wrote themselves
I mean yeah right the pro the prop
assistant I think and we had no idea
what was written on there but it doesn't
matter
you're just like
just watching the subtlety of watching
you try to understand the two people
that are sitting in front of you and
it's so subtle that's the thing like I
would actually love to ask you that
um as a as an actor as a performer
especially as a comedy person like how
do you have the how is it just your
natural inclination to just keep it
super like grounded and kind of real uh
I mean I'm assuming that's a very
specific choice but how do you trust
because I remember like there was part
of me that was always trying to figure
that out early on when I was working in
because I didn't start in comedy so like
I was trying to figure out how like how
does it what plays better like is it
because I found if I played it too
natural yeah sometimes it was boring and
then if I played it too big I felt like
it was too broad and I'm like trying to
figure that out I just saw something you
were saying about you accepted the
absurdity of it or you're trying to make
it very real early on yeah I don't know
I've done some some things in sketch
comedy where which were really over the
top yeah maybe the audience is laughing
but then I just felt like I was really
pushing but depending on the situation I
mean this one you guys got to be the
insane thing and I just got to sort of
settle back and relax into the trying to
figure it out more but I've been on both
ends I don't know well it's either a
gift that you have naturally or just
that you've honed it by you know being
on stage trying to make something funny
for so long right because a lot of
people could read that same resume and
react to it with their natural uh
reactions and it just wouldn't quite be
as funny it's just a mostly I think it's
a timing thing like how long you keep a
stare on us yeah when you pause with
what you say that it just makes it funny
okay and then uh we have 2005 to 2006
education
no it was a very educational year and we
did many odd jobs
here and there
that guy's funny man
2005 to 2010 education all year the
memory gray hair okay two years
it just says odd jobs here and there
I'm running the scene for you that's the
closest you can actually breaking
okay you know what let's go the last
thing is education 2005 to 2006 odd jobs
here and there here and there
wait uh almost everybody
here and there but mostly here
in there
[Laughter]
yeah that was one of the first times a
guests are genuinely cracking us up and
just and just also just not being able
to get through a scene like just being
like although it wasn't the scene which
was what was so fun about it like we
found a whole other thing of you just
reading this resume I don't think anyone
knew until you started reading it how
funny that resume was but you know what
I feel like it's a real missed
opportunity to not have cut it where you
read out the resume
oh have not cut the episode have have
that all be in the episode yeah I do
think I know why we didn't do it because
we did need you to hire us and we were
we were probably like if he goes to this
absurd resume and we do these funny
reactions to it and he's so super put
off
how are we gonna get him I was more put
off in the outtakes than the actual yeah
how are we gonna get you to where we
need you to be which is to hire these
characters for the episode I remember
when I was on the first time the I had
seen the show but I didn't really look
it up I didn't know you guys created and
we're like pretty much and so I remember
like oh they're really letting us
improvise a lot I kept saying they and
I'm like yeah yeah I hope they use I
hope they use that yes and you guys yes
I remember you saying that yeah I I hope
they I hope they use this and we're like
yeah no we will yeah yeah actually but
they actually roll yeah remember you're
like yeah we can do that we can do
whatever we want I don't know what year
was that was I don't know if my smart
smartphone asked me but later I'm like
okay oh they run the show I think we
should like if I take it if I could go
back I would have set a precedent where
uh where someone like when people showed
up the ad would be like just so you know
the set is a little bit unconventional
the the actors that you're going to be
acting in a scene with are also going to
be directing you even though they're not
the director but they created the show
you know because I think it was a great
great set I mean I didn't know you guys
you know yeah yeah but it's weird it
could be weird or off putting for an
actor to suddenly start getting
direction from the other actors that are
in the scene that's like exactly what
you're not supposed to do I remember
thinking that that wasn't weird to you
no
I somehow knew that they were letting
you guys play they but yeah seem to
remember that Glenn took we'll do this
from time to time where you were
pretending like you were getting
frustrated with us because we were
ruining the scene over and over you know
some how sometimes we'll be like okay
enough enough like get through it
because even though you we know you know
it doesn't work we try it so much like
guys you're [ __ ] this up and then it
just makes it worse it works is uh I
found is thinking some horrible uh
thought
like thinking like oh uh I'm abandoning
my child by being at work I've abandoned
my child abandoned my child like I have
to go so dark and that will only work
for like five seconds until my brain
calls [ __ ] on it I know that it's
the scene will be its best if I'm pushed
myself and we've pushed each other to
the brink absolutely we can't take it
and like if I Tamp down that sort of
like manic
comedic energy
it doesn't it's not as funny yeah yeah
so it's it's living on that like Razor's
Edge of like oh this is this shouldn't
we we shouldn't be saying this or
whatever it is that like uh right now
that's why this blooper is like a
classic I think this is one of the
favorite bloopers because you live for
so long in that space where you're like
right on the edge yeah all the time it's
funny I can be a breaker but I think I
was just I was on the show for the first
time yeah so I was too scared to like
waste people's time yeah yeah I was too
scared
but when you're playing a straight man
character do you have like do you have a
process like that to make sure you're
not like laughing in the scene yeah I
mean doing
the ground Lanes like Live Theater I've
been guilty of like breaking and I'm
like oh I'm embarrassed and I ruined the
thing but uh
you see if it's someone else like like
there it's a lot more about like I'm
doing my sketch and then sometimes
you're doing the other person wrote this
and it's their time to shine I think I'm
a little better
if it's someone else's thing that I
don't want to like ruin then I think
we're laughing at your performance
you're very familiar with your own work
so you probably don't think that what
you're doing is half as funny as we do
because you're right until today
like you're just like you're just doing
your thing you're playing it the way you
want to play it and you're looking at
these two bozos in front of you just
like laughing their heads off and you're
just like I'm sure I'm pretty sure they
wrote this I'm not sure what the hell's
going on here like I'm just delivering
the information yeah but yeah you guys
are so funny though when we're making
this show it's like we're it's we're
it's not really like a play where we
it's locked in we know exactly what the
scene is you know we've written the
scene but we're kind of mining for the
funniest version of it right and we're
like we're digging around and we're
trying some things and trying some
reactions or trying some improvs or
trying a blocking thing that makes it
funnier and the only way to know if
you're achieving that is it's getting
you close to laughing so that's yeah
that's sort of the danger of like how we
make the show when it comes to Breaking
it's like well that's what we're trying
to do we're trying to make ourselves or
each other also the same way if I I feel
like if I'm not on the verge of breaking
it almost at any given moment I'm not
doing I'm not doing what needs to be
done to make the scene as funny yeah
the audience isn't there you don't know
if you're making them laugh so you just
gotta make sure
yeah yeah I mean I've said this many
times but uh my goal in in these scenes
is in my scenes is always to try and
make them break that's always my goal
how often have we made like the camera
operator like you see him laughing or
like you know that's the most gratifying
the camera and you're like all right
have you guys ever thought of doing like
a three camera like live audience
what if we did one episode with like a
live audience we've definitely discussed
it the energy of it would be fun I don't
know yeah it might not be I don't know I
also don't want I like I like the fact
that we're crammed in a tiny room and
you're reading a resume and we're like
jammed in there and like everyone is
squeezed to the edges to be able to
cross cover it like
I like that sort of contained energy for
me yeah something funny oh two people
sitting across a desk is like the best
bread and butter so it's often our best
scene yeah because it's usually two
people with an insane request or some
sort of an insane thing that they're
bringing into a room with someone who's
just like how did these people get in
here first of all right secondly what
are they talking about what is happening
right now that's why what like the maybe
the most common guest star line we write
in the history of the show is what is
happening like somebody literally trying
to figure out what the hell is happening
right why don't we remember all the
times that somebody didn't know what was
happening what is happening what is
happening what is happening what is
happening what is happening here what is
happening here I don't know what's
happening here what's happening what's
happening what's happening what is
silence
foreign
[Music]
from our sponsor better help better
helps online therapy service is great
for when you want to try therapy and are
looking for a convenient accessible and
affordable online option we've all been
there we've either gone to therapy or
strongly considered it I mean glenland
because people are chewing their food
too loud that's absolutely right I was
fixated on a problem and I needed a
solution did you try betterhelp I
actually wish that I'd been able to try
better help back when uh when I was
going through this because better help
matches you with the right therapist
after a very brief survey right so
you're saying you found a therapist
probably with great expertise in other
areas but not in chew volume anxiety
that is correct my search was limited by
who was nearest to me geographically not
to mention who had availability to see
me but neither of those are deal
breakers when it comes to online therapy
especially with better help's enormous
index of licensed therapists this is the
thing this is the thing right that's
that is what it is so I mean if I do end
up going back to therapy for it which I
I well might I tried better help you
know to see if I can specifically find a
I don't know like a chew volume expert I
guess and you can switch therapists at
any time so if the first one isn't
working out you can always choose
another ah I like what you did there
okay now what if Glenn's therapist
starts chewing their food loudly while
he talks see again that's the beauty of
online therapy you know I just mute them
and it's problem solving right there
sadly I can't mute people in real life
I'd love to be able to do that one day
and until then online therapy so you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com sunny today to get 10 off
your first month that's better
help.com sunny and always
chew with your mouth shut
[Music]
I'll be giving to our friends over at
manscaped TM the sense of trademark uh
everyone loves turkey and stuffing but
you'll you'll be looking like dessert
with the help of manscape's performance
package 4.0 tell your in-laws about your
new Cutting Edge ball trimmer tell them
enough about Thanksgiving though I'm
already thinking about Christmas well
even better gift yourself or a man in
your life the performance package 4.0
hey Glenn can you tell me what's in
there inside the performance package 4.0
you'll find the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold all that new
swag Santa if you happen to be a
listener or a creep you can get 20 off
and free shipping with the code sunny at
manscaped.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscaped.com and use the
promo code sunny me Santa you've been
going around with a big beard for a long
time and I catch you I bet you got a big
bush in those pants too okay so be
thankful this holiday season for the
best gift of all from manscaped your
balls will thank you trademark
[Music]
should we watch some more yeah Michael
Martin another classic the gang dines
out
[Applause]
I was here first I know they see me
probably over there right now making fun
of me I get it guys you know what
they're doing they're calling me
scarecrow because I'm all alone in the
cornfield scaring away the other birds
real funny you know what there's no
shame in a woman an adult woman taking
herself out to dinner enjoying her own
company I'm not gonna leave I'm not
gonna leave because I don't have to and
also I can't because I have a Groupon
for this evening that expires tonight it
does expire tonight doesn't it
maybe I could at least get a drink order
we're really busy tonight does the
Groupon cover drinks nope just the test
they anticipate like you know you know
you have to ask the question but you
know the answer is gonna and then she
gives you exactly what you expected and
you're like nope it doesn't I knew she
was going to ask that based on that you
know it's just that kind of [ __ ] man
actually it was your friends over at the
other table
and they wanted me to relate to you that
it's our most expensive bottle
they said to say that
this is you're standing watching you
guys laugh
you really you really are so much more
of a prick as the waiter I mean and it's
because of what you're getting from us
obviously and you're you're at your
wit's end but pretty quickly I I'm
you've turned pretty yeah I don't put a
nice face on them
you're your ability to do the straight
man thing is for us a gold mine because
so much of what the show is is
these irrational characters put into a
rational situation and having someone
who can be the eyes of the audience but
deliver those reactions in a way that's
also funny is like
it's just it's the that's what we're
looking for with almost every guest star
you know it's just it's just a tough
thing to do it's a really hard thing to
do and then the gang guides out
specifically You're such the glue that
like holds all the things together
because everyone is separated and you're
the one going from table to table and
everywhere yeah any other guests are I
gotta go call my wife and kids and tell
tell them all the things you're saying
about me listen to the podcast oh yeah
oh yeah
on a road trip when they can't get away
from it yeah
you might be very unfunny straight man
at home I don't know on the show you're
sure your kids don't think they're fine
I'm the funny one
[Music]
what are you people doing what is
happening here
basically excuse me what are you people
doing oh
your own stunt yeah oh yeah yeah
try I
I remember there being a stunt man and
then I was like I thought there was a
shot where he did something but that
looked like that was my face that was
that was you they didn't need a stunt
man for that just kind of yeah I think
it was a game day
maybe two takes I don't know yeah I
remember them we had another shirt ready
I don't remember yeah that's a big reset
my yeah kids eight and eleven my
children can't watch the show yet you
know because there's a lot yeah so I did
show him this when I think they're
pretty young but they didn't like you
guys they were just out there yeah
that turns like yeah
they're gonna be happy so daddy why are
those guys
yeah they were just like those guys are
mean so I haven't reintroduced it yet
yeah yeah because you continue to be
mean so there's no also like he's got
he's got girls so yeah oh they're
sweeters yeah yeah they're nicer yeah
yeah boys are uh yeah yeah yeah you got
Daddy oh maybe yeah yeah yeah totally
they're protective absolutely
who cares what Frank prefers we're
buying this food with his stolen credit
card and I'm gonna pretend I didn't hear
that
welcome back gentlemen kind of just
trying to be friends
I waited on you before
you tied my shoelaces together fell down
I'm getting nothing I'm drawing a blank
on this guy yeah that means nothing to
me what are you saying a scalding hot
plate of spaghetti fell into my face I'm
to remember every man I've seen Fallen
to a plate of spaghetti classic line I
just remember every man I've seen fall
into a plate of spaghetti yeah one of my
favorite lines ever yeah it's very
specific thing to have happened okay so
then this is the first time we we
established that we we don't really we
don't we don't recall this person yes
yes season 10. and then you played that
through in this episode where multiple
times during this episode you continue
right right throughout the course of a
day yes you know it's it's uh we keep
going back to the restaurant yes yeah we
keep going back yeah yeah it's a running
theme of the show though when someone
who we've treated so horribly is so in
in that moment of of like ruining a
person's life is so insignificant to us
we don't right remember who they are we
don't remember we don't know their name
we don't know and it's kind of like no
it means nothing to us yeah yeah but you
can tell that they must enjoy you as a
straight man because your character has
escaped relatively unscathed like David
was the straight man in one episode and
then he was like hooked on crack and
like right right a Milky eye like an
episode later it's similar insofar as we
don't we we remember Cricket but we
don't have any clue as to what our
culpability is in his in his demise yes
what happened to that guy yeah yeah yeah
crank it yeah exactly I should watch out
for him yeah he's a mess
I'm gonna have the Snapper and I'm gonna
buy one for the strange man behind me
who I've never met gentlemen I hate to
inform you too
strangers here
we had some issues with our local
suppliers so we are completely out of
fish today how do you not have fish it
says fresh
from the menu I just explained it it's
right here can I get you a non-fish
entree you can get lost with pleasure
[Laughter]
when I was dealing with you guys I felt
like I was a little more I wasn't as we
were giving it a shot I was trying to
hit the reset
buttons like a rational human being
which is yeah we had a thing and I was
mad for a while but it's been two years
and you guys are sorry
you guys are sorry who are you he was in
a better place in his life yeah he
wasn't as rattled at first I mean he did
get rattled by the end yeah you were
definitely not as flustered as you were
and the Gang dines out but I think that
was because I mean I imagine it's
because we established it you're very
busy and it's like it's super crowded in
the middle of the day that makes sense
right yeah that's okay right good good
good yeah
it's a different time of day yeah all
right yes
season 13 episode nine the gang wins the
big game
can we get some binoculars up in here
too oh my God
how did I move all the way to Minnesota
and I'm still waiting on you people yeah
what are you talking about hey man what
if I told you there's a berry that can
handle all your Fitness leads I'm good
but thank you I'm just gonna go do my
job
how did you do that and looked like we
had a dummy I don't know we must add a
fall pad for you yeah
that must have hurt it looks like you're
doing the worm I love that Rex is on the
invigoran barrier yeah I remember
wanting to do that but when I saw it I'm
like oh my God
so this is the same season then the the
ladies reboot okay you know what the
reboot was first it was and then I
mentioned
waiting waiting on you at the Super Bowl
but when you did the Super Bowl it was a
flashback yeah
so the Super Bowl was a flashback yeah
yeah it was yeah right so he had moved
to Minneapolis from Philly yeah he was
working here he lost this job and then
later became a flight attendant and
that's how he ended up in the ladies
reboot because that yeah
hey you serve it
servants what do you got
huh how do I keep winding up with you
people
do I know you do you
I used to work at gugino's
and then I moved to Minnesota and I
waited on you guys at the Super Bowl
which the audience hadn't seen yet yeah
yeah no forget it
yeah what can I do for you look uh we're
doing the Box thing I don't know what
that is
big box
okay is that a person's name doesn't
matter by the way I love the details
after many many times you're like it's
fine whatever you move past it but you
you don't know what she's talking about
with the Wade box she's immediately
irritated
we're doing this
the most clarification she'll give you
is Wade Boggs God this man is so
irritated yeah yeah
I don't know who he is annoying human
being so that that episode aired before
the Super Bowl bowl episode did it have
to air that way I don't know we don't
always get everything right you know
what I mean check out a lot it made
sense with some flashback it was a
flashback right I can't it was an Easter
egg yeah it was an appointed to a
flashback yes that's right a classic a
Super Bowl One Two is a two-parter so it
might have something to do with like FX
not wanting to do a two-parter like at
the top of the Season or something I
think it made sense I think you guys
thought about when you wrote it thanks
man thanks
we do try to think about it yeah here's
uh is a question for you have you ever
been a waiter Michael oh yeah yeah you
have it was sort of in between I was
I was working a midnight shift at a Book
Bindery like driving a forklift so I was
able to during the day go to auditions
and take classes but it was you know
exhausting it was like you'd sleep
during the day but you'd have to get up
for an audition so then I got a job at
um like Jerry's Deli for a few one in
Studio City near the Beverly Beverly
Center okay yeah but it was horrible
because when you first started started
out it's like uh you know the shift
where like people are getting out of the
bar and you're you're your section is
like the back you know way back in the
patio so you know you get like 14 drunk
people who just want free bagel chips
and so yeah when you got the bug you
said you said I'm going straight to La I
sort of just let the two years at Henry
Ford Community College end and then
started auditioning for like summer
stock and I didn't make it big like I'm
gonna become a theater major or move I
sort of spent a couple years in Michigan
um doing Summer Stock and booking like
America's Most Wanted they were shooting
on location there you did some
reenactments yeah I got killed because
they were shooting where the murder took
place
they came to like the CBS where the
murder took place yeah Flint Michigan
and
um yeah I got killed and Meg can we roll
on that
um
you scared me to death ah you should
have seen him at school today so hyper
gonna be full-time next year Bertha you
got it come next Fall I'll have a
classroom full of the Little Devils oh
we'll miss you around here okay I'm gone
foreign
book things in Detroit like I had a very
high like I'd have an audition and I'd
probably get it right because there's
not a lot of but but at a certain point
then you have to have make the decision
okay this is something I want to do with
my life yeah and I think anyone who
tries to do it for real and Earnest has
to make the choice of where to go to do
it where they can actually have a career
yeah
right I was going to go to Chicago maybe
do Second City and then some friends
were going to Las I'm like I just kind
of well when was there a point at which
and I do think I do think it's
interesting for people who are
interested in the acting profession
certainly
um you know who aren't whose path to
success in the entertainment industry is
not as clear as others like you know
where you're literally taking one step
at a time you know because like you know
if you go to a major theater College you
could get scouted straight out of
college and you know your career could
start right away yeah it sounds like you
built it slowly one step at a time yeah
I mean I think that's interesting for
people to hear how you did that
yeah it's funny because doing Summer
Stock that I mentioned somehow I thought
it was so important to get it with like
Actors Equity points or something to get
your professional theater Union of
course and then I came out to LA and
like none of that mattered and it was
all about sag so
yeah I kind of meandered I don't think I
knew exactly what to do you know I came
out here knowing nothing and I'm like oh
maybe I'll do this improv class or it's
okay so you're doing Summer Stock and
then you just you're like you're
thinking you're considering going to
Chicago for Second City was there a
point at which you were like I feel like
comedy is my thing you know what I mean
were you or was it just like I'm also
interested in comedy so I'm gonna go do
some comedy stuff I always an actor like
when people would be like oh my he's a
comedian I'm like no I'm not I'm like an
actor but I like comedic acting
um and I just did some improv in in Ann
Arbor Michigan I was doing like Comedy
Sports School in Ann Arbor oh you did
yeah I went to U of M yeah I'm from
Michigan originally yeah oh okay
Kalamazoo oh Kalamazoo I'm there for a
little bit yeah oh did you use
Meandering yeah oh yeah there's a
girlfriend that lived there and I didn't
know what I was doing for a few months
wait are you my dad no
daddy no no no no no just checking okay
I'm gonna find him someday
but yeah I just I kind of like improv so
I did that but um
yeah I always felt like I was an actor
not like you know I would never do
stand-up or I don't know if you guys
have done that but I never I never felt
like a huge you know I I do feel like
the majority of uh actors on our on our
show and us all kind of did a similar
route where we were like we really want
to be actors we take acting seriously
and then suddenly realize oh wait we can
kind of do the comedic acting and yeah
create an opportunity and then you fall
in love with doing it yeah our approach
has always been to to approach it as
like you know real acting thing you know
what I mean right the characters really
fighting for what they want you know
basic acting kind of stuff and it's just
that you know what the character is
fighting for is ridiculous and that's
what makes it fun right but right um you
know but then there is also like just
that this there's just a certain amount
a certain way to time jokes and to put
inflection on things or hold a look or
whatever it is yeah that that makes it
funny but uh it makes sense to me to
hear you say that you started really
just in just as an actor you've always
thought of yourself as an actor yeah
how to dial it to make it funny
yeah yeah I guess yeah some people grow
up just knowing every comedian and they
just you know
their knowledge of Comedy yeah it was
more like I did a play in high school
I'm like oh this is kind of fun you know
right and I
yeah
but growing up I don't think my um you
know some kids are exposed to everything
my house is a little conservative so
like you know like we couldn't watch
through his company that was a little
racy and oh really and even Mash was a
little racy because they chase nurses
and stuff so so once you grow up I do
remember my dad loved the Pink Panther
movies oh okay you know yeah yeah it's
good stuff there a lot of Happy Days and
but yeah I didn't grow up like you know
knowing like George Carlin and all that
right oh she was more like
yeah I didn't necessarily know that
stuff either yeah yeah yeah the same way
I mean an actor but yeah did I answer
anything
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
we are supported by athletic greens and
their delicious green powder ag1 a
product I use literally every day oh you
do okay because I've never heard you
pipe up about it yeah but that's because
the two of you both jump in and make it
the whole thing about yourselves which
is kind of what I feel like you're doing
here right now I'm just I'm just stating
facts I drink it every day for better
energy and gut health okay well I mean
if you like it so much more than we do
why don't you prove it and tell me
what's in a scoop of ag1 oh yeah with
one scoop you're getting 75 high quality
vitamins minerals Whole Food Source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens to
help you start your day right okay fine
a lucky start but uh how about you tell
me how much sugar is in it less than a
gram of sugar per scoop plus no GMOs
nasty chemicals or artificial anything
and it works with any diet come on these
are gimmies guys rob you are correct
we've underestimated you yeah let's just
make it easy on them right athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is go to athleticgreens.com Sunny
that's right again that's athletic
greens.com Sunny to take ownership over
your health and pick up the ultimate
daily nutritional Insurance
well now that Halloween is over wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait oh
come on today is Halloween it's not over
today's the day we'll do Halloween like
that Meg yeah well I mean technically
today is October 31st yes but we don't
publish this episode for another week so
by the time the fans hear this Halloween
will already be a fading memory and
we'll be on to the next major season
shipping season oh shipping season now
shipping season is where people get into
relationships to avoid freezing to death
by themselves in the cold of winter
right yeah that's cuffing season season
but you're you're close shipping season
is basically that plus you know a bunch
of boxes arriving at your door and if
you have an online store you know the
feeling of getting hit with a ton of
orders all at once right so when you're
buried in orders and emails from
customers or buried under ice because
you didn't cuff with a mate You'll wish
you had ship stations so this holiday
season give yourself the gift of
stress-free holiday shipping use promo
code sunny today at shipstation.com to
sign up for your free 60-day trial
that's shipstation.com promo code sunny
foreign
I think there's something sweet about
then getting to discover that stuff in
your formative years you know when you
have freedom from your parents and then
there's a whole world of like wait a
second like uh this Richard Pryor guy
yeah yeah he's pretty funny yeah and my
dad was really funny he was that was
funny yeah my mom
yeah she didn't always get it
I like this period of your life that you
said you were you you just happen to
live in Kalamazoo for a few months
um you were you were a bit of a Drifter
and I like to think that maybe there was
a period of time but you've also said
like your mom didn't get it you were a
Drifter throughout Michigan
you haven't revealed a ton about
yourself and I'm wondering if maybe
you you you're wanted oh are you are you
want to maybe no you don't have a killer
always go like you know goes back to the
scene of the crime yeah and that's
pretty hard that'd be pretty baller if
you're actually doing the reenactment of
the murder that you did except you know
what together I said Flint Michigan yeah
some of my wandering during that couple
years in Michigan I was a a train robber
at like a historical Village in Flint
Michigan he's made me think of it
because I was like we were the
characters you play yeah we'd Rob the
train and we're like wanted in town and
it was during those wandering years so
maybe that's what you learned a killer
like a real like homicidal person can
also be funny that would be really
impressive
yeah I think you could be like you do it
yeah you could make someone laugh while
you were killing them Bill Cosby is
pretty goddamn funny and he was raping
women
there was recordings of Hitler but he's
making jokes like Trump yeah yeah yeah
by the way Trump is pretty funny
not directly maybe but indirectly yeah
well you know he certainly murdered our
culture
[Laughter]
well should we watch um should we watch
Michael's most recent I won't say final
uh clip because I'm sure we're gonna
have you back on the show
um but this is uh season 14 episode 4
the gang chokes and you have a lot of
scenes in this episode of Danny so we're
gonna watch a couple of them here
oh God you people oh this guy again come
on man what are you doing here this
isn't Reginos I moved back so wait you
guys remember me uh yeah you're
everywhere you can't get away from you
you know what we had to acknowledge them
little bowls blue I hope
no it's a moose boosh for the table
what's this what I think he's choking oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
I don't even know what that expression
means what is happening here
[Music]
okay folks we have a few specials
tonight
oh my God
he really committed to that
were you excited when you got the script
and there were so many scenes with you
yeah yeah yeah I couldn't yeah it was
great because a couple years every time
are you always surprised when you get a
call from us yeah yeah yeah you should I
always think it's the way it should
happen like you do a TV show and yeah
it's pretty funny and they'll you know
call you back but you guys actually do
it and then
for other shows we'll get into that
after this yeah oh yeah yeah
okay look I only saved you because
that's what any decent person would do
but I don't need a roommate I already
live here with my mother oh that old
vegetable lady's your mom
now you don't have to worry about her I
took care of her took care of her what
do you mean I threw a sheet over her
head she was freaking me out
all right Mom
I felt bad that was a hot day and that
woman had that blanket over yeah yeah
that's right I do remember they tried to
minimize it did you drag this episode
then I can't remember I did yeah yeah I
did right you know actually can we roll
it back to when when
um Michael's walking down the stairs at
the very beginning of the scene and tell
me this does not look like Nick Cage
yeah
expression on there
do you often get confused for Nicholas
Cage no no are you trying to do a
Nicholas Cage that's pretty good I don't
have it have you done it that is that
something that you've done like on stage
thing I've ever seen in my life
no it's the it's also the yeah yeah I
tried it in a sketched it was horrible
really yeah oh man I didn't quite get it
I'm doing impressions
and we've done that on the show
that's really funny who is that who are
you
thanks for sticking my mom in that home
never could have done it myself
she always said it's the last thing she
ever wanted so so thank you what thank
you well your mom said that's the last
thing she wanted was to be in a home
yeah yeah she said all the time so when
you saw her in there why'd you let her
stay well I didn't see her you took her
you mean you didn't have the decency to
go you told me not to to avoid the
emotion of it all well I told you not to
because I was sticking her in a bag
they're much cheaper I'm starting to
think I had you pegged all wrong I'm
sorry can we go back to the Bingham and
Venom thing I trusted my life with you
when you would treat your mother like
that I bet you'd let me get spit roasted
by Lion King just like that wouldn't you
I'm sorry I can't follow this
conversation where is my mom
where is my mother I remember writing
that argument and like crying laughing
with the
with the switch with the with that yeah
that he did put him in the radio yes yes
these horrible people came into his life
but they actually you know finally yeah
yeah brought his life to a good place
that's right yeah
oh my God why why are you people all
here hey man don't interrupt okay we're
not ready to order go well I couldn't
take your order if I wanted to because
I'm just here to beg for my job back
thanks to this guy
what is wrong with you people
okay uh
I remember
I think I was hitting Caitlyn's leg too
hard with the we had a joke she's gonna
sue you because you injured her oh yes
yes there was it was a joke in there
yeah oh yeah I think it yeah which I
think it just got cut but yeah where she
says she's gonna sue you because you're
gonna like too hard
this is your career on It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia it's not your career but
it's your sunny and Philadelphia career
how do you feel about it how do I feel
about this career yeah uh great I love
it well we're turning this back to be
about us yeah yeah
I felt like yeah
no it's not going anywhere no way what's
what uh do you do you get my I I am
curious though like to bring it back
around to uh to us
um do I get recognized yeah do you get
recognized for it is one of the most
things
yeah I used to be recognized for this
YouTube video but now yeah the David
Blaine video Sunny is the most
um it's usually someone younger
uh like at Starbucks or whatever
actually it's happened a lot at my local
Target because I'm there all the time
because I have kids and yeah and it just
happened there what's it usually like
when the sunny fans like yeah what do
they say
yeah are you the waiter I mean it's it's
usually 230 you know well actually they
usually know which I'm surprised usually
like is that the guy who but usually
they're like you're the waiter they seem
to know because they've watched the
episode 15 000 yeah or they want a
picture or um yeah oh cool yeah it's
funny though because on the street it's
almost always
pretty young like your demographic is
kind of but my father-in-law who's you
know 75 or whatever he's the biggest fan
like he jams up
um our DVR
he lives in the back house I feel like I
will just share it you know and so we
have we share a DVR and it's like 90
episodes yeah
well Michael it's been a pleasure having
you on the podcast thank you it's been a
pleasure having you on the show
um we're gonna do many more seasons and
hopefully you will return
um thanks you wouldn't know this Glenn
um but uh we Michael has been on Mythic
Quest
[Music]
Uncle Jack like Andrew Friedman one of
my best friends but we didn't intersect
a lot but in Mythic Quest they put us in
together in some scenes yes and are you
guys doing it are you guys doing a new
show together you and Andrew like a new
TV show uh there's something about it
let's talk about it he and Andrew wrote
a very funny uh movie that we we hope
gets made and gets out there in the
world deserves to get made and the
audience will love it speaking of you
and Andrew that would be a great
direction to go with the show just
combining you and Uncle Jack somehow
right whether he's your new roommate or
whatever it is but yeah but it was
exciting they put us on Mythic quests
together yes that's great hopefully we
will have you back we'll have you back
many many very fun and we've very much
exploited just basically writing very
little for you and then being like just
riff
well thanks for having me on I mean yeah
you're doing Sunny is one of the most
fun things I've ever done and uh and
then coming here the waiter's on
yeah man that's right the Reddit ass for
it I guess they did they're gonna be
psyched it's not give give the people
what they want yeah we just do and then
they receive
it's free so just like that it's free
they can't really plan it's free it's on
the internet we won't know when this
ends right I mean this podcast
it
probably already ended yeah
foreign